hey guys i'm ryan right hi it's so so
you guys might know so hey
people rhyme her name a lot don't they
yeah yeah must be annoying so is a
american korean filemaker uh film
reviewer i wanted to specify your
ethnicity Reno but I saw her channel
she's really good at what she does
film critic love it and she does the
occasional trailer reaction here and
there yes I asked her she could come on
and in a heartbeat she was like yeah no
problem I've been a fan for a very long
time it was very surprising when you
asked me thank you thank you you prepare
that statement didn't you it's like I
was waiting for your call there's a man
in the woods no idea what this video is
I don't know if it's a trailer I've
never heard of that viral video so let's
watch this okay yo get ready for more of
that classic comedy create a comedy
people one two three there's a man in
the woods
spectacle before the story started this
school was still respectable my students
used to skip down the hill to the
honeysuckle pluck a couple or collect
the nectar till they picked their fill
except one obnoxious kid SID who just
watched them eat the flowers while he
seemed dead scowled because he couldn't
bear to share his sweet treats
throughout our recess out
I remember Sid saying there's a man in
the woods that's how the rumors began of
course it had spotted first poor kids
he got an immersed in his spiel about a
serial killer shut their ugly head
santero
a visit to the nurse or worse a hearse
waiting just be able to do the children
saw him everywhere
look over there that man had bad manners
we swear it crazy eyes we saw something
rusty a shotgun it must be I saw a lady
separate thigh trust me every word I
heard was absurd yet each day Sid would
straight down way past the playground
who else was very even tough to save us
from the killer's next plug the rest of
the lot would stop back blacktop sure
that any closer they were bound to be
found deep in the woods left to rot I
pleaded for the kids to think and learn
to be mature but after a few more rumors
duped by attempts to prove the school
was secure their fear was undeterred and
when the buses drove them all home the
parents finally heard everything just
blew up I received a wall of emails and
calls full of shrieks wails and all from
terrified family screwed earth word of
the murder and didn't like my lack of
action at all what was I supposed to do
comb the whole forest Yeah right with
you that means I didn't care that's not
fair the stories that worried you
weren't true of course I was feel regret
had there been a real threat and I
ignored it and some poor kid got
kidnapped while the kids were napping
but you couldn't admit that your good
little kid would formulate a fit so we
ignored what I said
your little angels could never cook up
such incredible creations an overactive
imagination maybe but my kid could never
lie
how dare I a few as a child of being
dishonest cuts mobsters burns we
displease them with the PTA tonight she
berated him to speak of the classroom I
they knew what was best for their kids
it is to get a job with a bitter boss
that is a rep of public like from the
outset now who's the controller glasses
single file line single file line little
file swine a killer by the line really
are you blindly find your spine sick a
child besides the fill our mind with
life other than thing you see is people
treating me like I've committed crime
I wouldn't like ride boomstick were
lucky Daffy you see what you think but I
can play of law I can be good do you
hear that see there's a man in the woods
I got chills
ooh cool wait so this is the trailer no
I think it's a like a spoken-word
animation okay so this is the whole
thing yeah that was Wow okay that wasn't
a very revealing trailer yeah yeah I was
like thanks so much yeah I just got to
watch the movie to fight it or not he
liked it so yeah that was cool that was
uh really yep you like dark stuff yeah I
was it was getting the atonement vibe of
like you can't trust kids damn you like
not another one making up lies where
Sid's always douche bags I don't know I
don't know other SIDS
the only set I thought of his toy story
so I must have assumed all SIDS are
douche bags and the way he looks so
sinister yeah yeah Candace kids up to no
good
it was really well done it was like
surprisingly like moving in its own dark
yeah you know what was cool about this
was you don't actually see yeah like
anything really happening that's
menacing or violent but yet it feels
like just to the expression of the
emotion you feel all this like
disgusting stuff going on I think you
know we're gonna like watch it one more
time
there's like so many oh yeah you have
two things got happening cuz who is the
man is he the man give me the whole time
well he's talking about like a man yeah
I thought he'd be pretended to be the
man at the end like he became noise oh
my god yes okay yes yeah it doesn't take
a second view I know I know I'm sorry
dad
there was just so I just felt like a lot
yeah I was trying to get every line okay
oh that's all right she was play was
really well done and I was like oh my
god there's like so many things
happening some cool rhyme yeah oh yeah
could be a good rap song I was just
thinking that I'm gonna we should make a
round should make a rap song Aaron yeah
that's very good that's good I enjoyed
it
I feel like murdering a bully now yeah
let's do it let's murder a bully oh man
huh nothing like talking about hurting
little kids best way to brighten up your
day anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects so has a channel those real
thoughts now it's kind of complicated to
spell like try typing in a few times
what the [ __ ] is her name yeah s o
apostrophe s r ee l ha stole that from
us as we're the only no I know that
before oh my god only once you've ever
done real that way thoughts okay so real
thoughts she does movie reviews a lot of
hindi flicks and you'd be like spit in
my mouth do a lot of any like festivals
and stuff I go to like tons of festivals
like to cover like international
independent and genre films so if you're
into that I'm your gal mmm-hmm yeah
check it out check it out
can't cook Ryan you said say something
interesting I have nothing interesting
to say perhaps in a way that's the most
interesting thing to say or not whatever
give me a shoutout preferably in a video
you crime but I'll take what I can get
can't cook you took the chance and guess
what I ain't crying you know there was a
little bit of a rhyme going on there so
he did I know he can rhyme me oh yeah
this is like perfect video this is
perfect we were talking about rhyming
earlier did it and we saw a video
and now he was rhyming chants cook what
are the chances you would get put in
this video zero well yeah it's not
really a big chance that means put your
name on a list and you're gonna get a
shout outside see it cooked up a good
one chance his name is chance good yeah
you get it yeah you get it yeah
Nicholas Reynoso so glad I found your
channel like seven hours ago on accident
while looking for raid fight scenes you
guys are all great and hilarious and it
makes me want to chase my dream of being
an actor that was kind of discouraged
when I found out I have Asperger's
syndrome damn she come real hell yes as
per your said you're like oh [ __ ] man I
don't want to ever reveal whatever
disease I develop down the road I have a
lot of diseases good for you I was been
around I was hoping you guys maybe had
some connections for me maybe a
shout-out please alright my friend with
Asperger's syndrome I have certain
conditions too I won't go into them
because that's personal but I did reveal
to her that I am diagnosed with ADHD
yeah that's one of three main ones and
she thinks she might have a DD and I'm
just like this everywhere oh yeah yeah
people think she does a lot of coke I
assumed she was a cocaine addict when
she came through the door apparently she
doesn't do a lot of cocaine um not a lot
but Nicholas back to you thank you so
much and what I wanted to tell you for
connections it's all about knowing how
to work that dick town if you know okay
you gotta be willing to do both guys and
girls but if you're willing to put your
body out there I'm telling you
damn you get the next big money how do
you think the capital got Titanic you
[ __ ] James Cameron facts so facts
that's what I like to leave people with
Rodney Tarot Tyrell the interstellar pod
was some pretty fantastic conversation
and I really think you guys hit the nail
on the head a shout out would make my
day and also Ryan I swear I saw a guy
who looks just like you want It's Always
Sunny keep up the great work
haha it was you it wasn't me I was on an
episode of It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia yeah underage drinking is
the name of the episode so you guys want
to see me
I got a hundred bucks from that last
week yeah see you I was just kidding
below no I'm really in it okay I don't
watch It's Always Sunny
Oh Oh going along with the joke okay I
just assumed
no not prom that's amazing that's
amazing
yeah totally amazing yes oh they don't
even know you yeah Jesus Christ Rodney
you're a nice guy I love your Robocop
thumbnail because Robocop like I gave
Nicolas advice you know he knows how to
work the wing and dangling so you make
it happen - okay can you give Rodney
advice on how to obtain an asian girl I
don't know that's what all Asian girls
say last time I asked that question
honestly I don't know it's always just
don't point out that they're Asian
that's like the number one step really
yeah you never that's like a flag to
them they're like oh my god this guy
knows not know is but like oh right
because I mean he's got a fetish yeah
okay
well Rodney you can that asian fetish
and I didn't mention it but I know you
have it everyone has it
everyone has an asian fetish I'm half
asian and most people don't realize that
half black
nice no I wish